donald trump fracasó en su intento de
lograr en las cortes lo que no logró en
las urnas de votación quedarse con el
poder por segunda vez esta semana a la
corte suprema de justicia rechazó la
demanda que pedía desconocer los
resultados electorales del 3 de
noviembre el martes se rechazó la
apelación de los republicanos en
pensilvania y ahora la corte en una
orden no firmada dice que la demanda de
texas y 17 estados más para que se
desconozcan a los resultados de georgia
pensilvania y wisconsin y michigan no
tiene fundamento legal porque
básicamente un estado como texas no
puede pedir que se desconozcan los
resultados electorales de otros estados
y evitar la votación de los delegados
electorales así entonces el lunes
votarán estos delegados electorales a
joe biden como próximo presidente de
eeuu para que la primera semana del año
2021 sea confirmado por el congreso y se
posesione el próximo 20 de enero